[Music]
hello everyone welcome the next I'm mark
fashion software engineer with the
Google Apps Script team here with my
co-presenter Daniel Florrie CEO of
Florrie soft and we are here today to
talk to you about something and we're
both really excited about building G
suite out ons with Google Apps Script so
let me give you an idea of where we're
going to go today first I'm gonna give
you a little bit of background on Apps
Script and add-ons for those who may not
be familiar with them then we'll talk
about how to code your own add-on from
scratch and how you would publish it and
then I'm going to hand off the
presentation to Daniel who's going to
show you the product that he's built on
our platform which i think is a really
powerful demonstration of the potential
of this platform and he'll do a live
demo as well showing how he's used
add-ons to more tightly integrate with G
suite products and then after that I'll
introduce a few of the new features that
we've got planned and we'll talk about
what you can do to get involved in
publishing add-ons and then there will
be a little bit of time for Q&A at the
end so first let me give you a little
bit of background
what is Apps Script Apps Script is a
serverless JavaScript runtime 4G suite
automation extension and integration
that's a bit of a mouthful but there's a
couple keywords in here
serverless of course Apps Script runs on
servers but the idea is that you don't
have to provision them so you might call
this zero provisioning and that's pretty
cool cuz it means you can write your
code and let us worry about the rest of
it and the other key word in here is G
suite Apps Script is purpose-built for
integrating with G suite products which
means we have a lot of built-in api's
that you can take advantage of that make
it easy to interact with Gmail and
calendar and drive and Docs and whatever
G suite products I you want to interact
with with your script with your add-on
with your web app so what are add-ons so
add-ons extend G suite products so you
can get the things you need to do done
and the key word here is extend add-ons
run inside G suite products creating
menu items dialogues side bars so that
you can build functionality into that
product in a seamless manner for example
let's say that you would want Docs to be
able to translate text into other
languages you can build an add-on for
that one of the unique things about
add-ons is that there are a true cloud
technology people throw around the word
cloud a lot you FRA heard it thrown
around a lot here but in the case of
add-ons it's really true because the
because add-ons are running in cloud
native Docs editors and they're running
on a cloud development platform it means
that for one thing they're all they're
always up to date so for example you've
got a new feature that you want to push
out to users in your add-on code it
redeploy and the next time that users
use that use that out on the feature
will be there for them they don't have
to download they don't have to reinstall
and this is pretty cool likewise
domain-wide install is made easy for
enterprise if you publish your out onto
the G suite marketplace domain admins
can install to their domain and then the
next time that users in their enterprise
use that product safe sheets that add-on
will already be there for them you don't
have to build an installer you don't
have to push it out to the workstations
it's easy to deploy and there are a
whole host of other advantages I've
listed some of them here but I don't
have time to talk through all of them
today so let's dive right into coding
I'm going to show you how to build a
simple sheets out on but first let me
set the stage for you so let's say that
you're a sheets power
user you really like using cheats but it
doesn't have all the functions that you
need that's okay
Apps Script lets you define your own
functions we call them custom functions
some people call them user-defined
functions some people call the macros
but you can go to the script editor and
write your own but then it's a bit of a
hassle to copy these around from sheet
to sheet you keep having to look back
your script to remember which ones you
wrote and now your teammates are asking
to use these functions too how do we
solve this problem
let's write an add-on and to make things
a little more interesting let's add some
built-in help so you might be familiar
with custom functions already but
basically the idea is when you're in
sheets and you need and you need another
function you can go into the Tools menu
and click script editor and that will
take you into the Apps Script script
editor and create a script for you
that's embedded in that sheet where you
can write functions an ordinary
JavaScript just like these ones I've
created here these are actual finance
functions from another popular
spreadsheet software we don't have them
in sheets but with this out on now we do
and you can invoke them in a cell just
like you would built-in function with
the familiar equals notation so let's
get the help page I was talking about so
we we created these custom functions and
I'd like to add some documentation in a
sidebar they when you're building
add-ons there's a special method that
Apps Script recognizes called on open we
call these methods simple triggers but
the idea is basically that if a user's
installed an add-on and they open a
sheet this on open method will get run
when they when they when they open the
sheet and this method as you can see
adds a menu item show doc
imitation that invokes this callbacks
show sidebar this other method we've
defined so that's pretty that's pretty
simple and then show sidebar itself is
not very complicated it just creates a
help page and then opens it in a sidebar
in the sheets UI so what does that help
page look like it's just a web page so
building sidebars is easy if you're
already familiar with the basic web
technologies like HTML CSS and
JavaScript and you can call server-side
functions in Apps Script from from your
sidebar client code by using the API
Google dot script run so in not very
much code we've we've done something
useful in sheets we've added some custom
functions that we didn't have before
we've added a menu item to open our help
page and we've added a sidebar and this
is what it actually looks like inside
sheets would we use this add-on you can
see I'm invoking the custom function and
there's the documentation in the sidebar
on the right that I open by clicking the
menu item which would show up in the
add-ons menu when you're ready to test
it in the script editor you can go into
the publish menu and click test is out
on this allows you to simulate different
install say it's on different documents
so you pick sheets that you want to try
your out on out on and select what kind
of installation configuration you want
but remember it's okay to make mistakes
it's like I said at the beginning of the
talk add-ons are always up to date which
means that if you have a bug in the out
on that you pushed it's very low cost to
fix it code the fix republish and the
next time your users use it they'll get
the bug fix so feel free to launch and
iterate on a very tight cycle
so now that you've seen how to code the
out on let's talk about deploying it and
what it looks like when a user uses it
so to deploy the out on you can go into
the publish menu in the script editor
and this time we're gonna click deploy a
Sheetz web add-on and what happens then
is that oh create is that will create an
entry in the Chrome Web Store for your
add-on and then we'll give you a link
you'll follow it and you'll go provides
a few bits of extra information and
icons some promo images a description of
the add on and then you'll decide who
you want to publish it to you can
publish it to the world you can publish
it to your business by publishing to a
domain you can publish it to a group of
trusted testers it's up to you who you
want to share your add-on with and then
if you want to allow enterprise users to
do domain wide installs you can publish
to G suite marketplace so we made an
add-on and now users can find it by
going into sheets and if you go into the
add-ons menu and click get add-ons
something that you can do right now you
can you can browse the Chrome Web Store
and search the Chrome Web Store for
add-ons that people have published in
the case of the add-on that I just
demoed I published it to a domain so you
won't have access to it but there are
hundreds of other add-ons that have been
published including add-ons that my
co-presenter daniel has published when
you install an add-on you'll almost
certainly see this prompt and I think
it's a it's important to know what this
prompt means Apps Script will
automatically determine which which
permissions the script requires to run
and so if your add-on accesses a user's
Gmail or accesses their email address or
accesses their sheets different
permissions will be displayed in this
prompt
and this prompt will ask the user for
exactly the permissions that your add-on
needs this is all managed for you if
you've heard of os/2 it's an industry
standard security model
that's what Apps Script is using but you
don't have to worry about it because
it's built in and that means that users
can trust your add-on to only access the
data that you've that you've requested
permission that they've explicitly
authorized so I'd like to walk briefly
through what it looks like when a user
installs an add-on so let's say user
Alice goes through the Chrome Web Store
and she gets an add-on from the store
well now let's say she installed a
Sheetz out on when she opens a sheet now
the add-on will run in a very limited
mode that basically exists to be able to
add menu items inside sheets when she
uses the ad on the out on one with all
the privileges that she authorized when
she installed the add-on but another
interesting thing will happen to that
document now now other triggers like on
triggers like on open and on edit and on
install will run with additional
privileges but more importantly when
user Bob who's never installed this
add-on opens the sheet the on open
trigger will also run and this is an
important feature for collaborators
because if Alice's use this out on in
the document chances are Bob wants to -
and when Bob goes to use the out on by
selecting one of these menu items that's
when Bob will be prompted to install the
add-on from the Chrome Web Store
and at that time Bob will authorize the
access required for that add-on to run
as bob is this an important way for
users to discover your add-ons
when collaborators on their documents
have used them so now you've seen how to
build a relatively simple add-on I want
to give you an impression
what the true potential of this platform
is and I can't think of a better person
to do this than my co-presenter Daniel
Florrie CEO of Florrie soft who's built
his product ultradox on the apps
developer platform and uses add-ons to
more tightly integrate with G suite
products okay Thank You Marc and thanks
for the opportunity to show ultradox and
the OtterBox add-ons here at next so for
all of you who have never heard of
ultradox before let me give you a very
brief idea what it is and why we made it
so we've created ultradox to enable
people with or without coding skills to
automate the business and create
enterprise apps so can we go to the
slides
okay so ultradox comes with a set of
high-level building blocks and you can
create automations or apps by assembling
these building blocks using our
drag-and-drop interface and as most
Enterprise related business processes
also involve documents and emails
ultradox also comes with a very powerful
template engine that you can use to
generate PDF Word or LibreOffice
documents right in the cloud and also to
create a responsive emails so once
you're happy with your flow you can then
plop publish your app with a single
click and use it right away on your
browser on your mobile device or your
desktop so and I think this combination
of features really works so we have a
large number of customers from
universities schools and for example law
firms who are able to automate their
business which is not very surprising
because the brain of a lawyer seems to
be quite similar to the brain of a
developer so they all also like to think
in rules but we also have a number of
customers that you would not expect in
the first place to
create apps by themselves so it for
example like this revi from the G suite
marketplace as I am at researching my
computer skills are not amazing I'm much
better with a chainsaw ultradox has
enabled me to create my own coding
machine and so on so I think this gives
a good impression of the variety of
customers
okay so ultradox comes with a number of
bandit add-ons you can see that in the
works with section when going to the g
suite marketplace and that's pretty nice
because once you install ultradox from
the g suite marketplace you get all the
bundled add-ons installed right away and
this installation flow works fine no
matter if you are using a personal gmail
account or if you are adding it to your
dress we two main as an admin so
ultradox comes with add-ons for Docs
sheets and forms and I will show you our
Docs and forms add-ons in a minute when
installing ultradox you also get a
dedicated fire type on Google Drive so
you can create edit and share ultra Docs
files on Google Drive just like the
native file types and I think this tight
integration and seamless integration is
what really sets the G suite ecosystem
apart from the competition because you
can really create third-party
applications that work almost in the
same way as the standard G suite
applications okay so now it's time to
pray to the demo God because I want to
try to create an application from
scratch live on stage and I would like
you to go to this URL because that
should take you to a Google Form and I
will try to create an automation that
will get triggered by a Google form and
then will create a personalized PDF
document and send it as an attachment to
you by email
so just open the Google form don't
submit it right now because it will not
do anything just for yet but we will use
that in ten or fifteen minutes okay so
hopefully some of you have the form open
already oh okay
otherwise ask the guys next to you for
the URL okay so can we switch to the
demo machine so when logging into ultra
Doc's you will find a number of
pre-built solutions similar to what you
see when logging into Google Docs but
each of these solutions comes with a
number of files so when using these
examples as a starting point you will
then get a folder on your Google Drive
containing all the involved files so we
have ready-made solutions from simple
newsletter signup systems generating
invoices from a timesheet up to more
complete applications like our famous
PDF invoicing for stripe that you can
add to your stripe account to
automatically send out nice PDF invoices
to your customers or complete approval
flow flows like the purchase order
example but for this demo I will just
start with a blank document so you can
also create a blank document from the
Google Drive new menu so when opening a
new document a wizard will pop up to
guide you through the most common use
cases but in this example as I hopefully
should know what I'm doing I will just
get rid of that and start from scratch
first of all I'll give our file name so
that when switching to Google Drive you
will then find the corresponding fire
with a ultradox file I can overhear okay
so as I'm let's first of all have a look
at the editor so on the left hand side
you will find a number of building
blocks that you can use to create your
application from very simple stuff like
uploading downloading files from Google
Drive to more complex building blocks
for example a complete checkout flow
that you can add to your application by
simply dragging that building block to
your flow but as I said I wanted to
start with a Google Form I will use this
building block and when creating a
building block that is referencing an
external file you can either create a
new file from scratch or select an
existing one from Google Drive so I will
take the one that I've prepared and I
think that's the one that you hopefully
have open on your mobile device or
laptop so each building block comes with
some input on the left-hand side and
output on the right-hand side so I will
add some dummy data sets so that I can
test my flow without submitting the form
each time
so next I want to generate a PDF
document from a Google document so I
will track this Google Docs to PDF
document building block to the flow and
I will select Google document that I've
prepared for this demo so when going to
Google Docs this will open just plain
Google document and in Google Docs you
will now find the ultradox add-ons and I
will get started with the Alteryx
template editor so this one has been
designed to help you when working on
documents that end up as a PDF or Word
document so in the sidebar you will now
find all variables from the building
blocks that you have added to your flow
in our example we just have the
variables from the Google Form so if I
want to personalize this document I can
just go here and click on the name
variable and this will bring up a bunch
of formatting options like printing the
string in uppercase letters only other
stuff like that but I will just insert
it as it is and I can also add the x
term as a date and as ultradox has
detected that the response time stamp is
of type date you will now get a lot of
date formatting options so this is
probably not very important in the
United States but if you are sending out
invoices in Europe or across the world
and its really the tricky part to get
all the date currency number formatting
right so ultradox also helps you with
that but aside from these simple math
texts you can also use more complex
stuff in your templates like loops or
conditions so I have created a table
where certain table rows will be then
visible depending on the road that you
are picking in your form
so when clicking on the preview icon we
should now get a PDF preview using the
dummy data that I've entered into my
form and with a text block for the pict
role okay so next I want to create an
email that I want to send out with this
document attached so as I want to use a
nice HTML email I will use the Google
Docs to HTML building block and this
time I will start with a blank document
so let's and we can now check out the
email designer add-on so our email
designer add-on comes with a bunch of
predefined layouts that play nicely on
desktop and mobile devices so that's
always the tricky part when sending out
HTML emails so I will get started with a
very simple theme and the basic concept
is that you assemble your emails from
predefined modules so you will find a
number of matching modules in the
sidebar and some modules have already
already been assembled as a starting
point so this is just an ordinary Google
document so I can go ahead and work on
it just like you know it already and I
can get rid of some columns that I don't
need and for this demo now I want to
show is a more advanced feature of
ultradox you cannot only insert very
simple data like the name and time stem
that we've seen but also ultradox is
also able to deliver
complex data so as an example let's load
some data from a Google sheet so I've
prepared a sheet with some of the
recommended sessions of the next day's
and now you will see all the available
columns and the she'd as Airy variables
on the right-hand side of the building
block so this is the simple sheet that
I've prepared and these are the
corresponding variables that you will
now get in
Ultra Docs so in the email designer you
will also find the variables tab where
you can insert variables that you have
been loading before in your flow so now
I can go ahead and insert some variables
that I've just loaded from the Google
feed for example title and description
of the session and I can also do more
fancy stuff like rendering this image
URL as an image so I can now specify
some images with specific formatting
options the name of the speaker so and
the nice thing is ultradox knows that
these variables are Aries so they
contain multiple values so when
generating a preview of this email
ultradox should now automatically expand
the variables from the she'd and create
an entry for each row in the sheet
mm-hmm okay took a while so you will see
an entry for each row in the sheet so
the row in the email has been repeated
automatically so that's pretty nice when
dealing with more complex data
structures so for example when creating
invoices this is always the tricky part
to have to display complex data on the
right-hand side you will find a preview
for mobile devices and on the left-hand
side you will see how this will look
like on desktops okay let me just switch
to a nicer version of this email that
I've prepared and finally I want to send
out this email
let's HTML document as an email so we
can take the sender address and otras
provides various email providers so you
can send out both using a gmail account
or you can also use Amazon SES that
allows you to track your email delivery
and deliveries and bounces okay so I
want to attach the PDF document that
we've generated previously
and I will also try to track these
emails so I can
I could either trigger certain actions
whenever the email gets delivered or
opened but I just want to use Google
Analytics to track the email deliveries
so I will have to copy and paste and
finally as this is a cloud conference
and I want to push the cloud to its
limits I will also add a Google Cloud
Print building-block so this will print
the PDF document that we are generating
right from the cloud on the printer in
my office back in Germany so this is a
very nice feature because of you for
example are generating invoices you have
an online shop and you are triggering
the invoice generation then you could
open for example automatically print out
the invoices in the office of your
account and stuff like that so I think
that's pretty nice with Google Cloud
Print ok I almost forgot to switch on
the trigger in the Google form so in
Google Forms you will find the ultradox
trigger add-on and this one will allow
you to trigger the flow that we've
created whenever a form gets submitted
and you will also will also be able to
rename the variables so but you thought
they are based on the question toilet so
that's fine with me
okay so let's now try that
Oh somebody already submitted the form I
guess let's check so okay you can also
give it a try and the nice thing is that
you can see in real-time in ultradox if
anybody is submitting the form but I
want to do themselves
okay so I should receive an email the
attachment and we can also go to Google
Analytics and check if we okay somebody
did not enter the correct email but at
least okay so this is the email that
I've just received and attached I would
find the personalized PDF document
so let's finally check if the printing
works so so I asked my sister to look
okay because it's midnight it's now in
Germany so something is going on there
[Applause]
right okay so that's all from my end
back to you Daniel I think that's a
pretty cool presentation of what you can
build with add-ons Daniel showed you
both the docs Anna forms out on so now
you've you've seen the whole space
covered and sheets well you think you've
seen the whole space covered
can we oh yeah we are back on slides
awesome so I'm gonna tell you about some
of the new exciting features that we've
got in the works so first off mobile
add-ons have been out for a while these
are these aren't really new anymore but
we have the support for Docs and sheets
and the cool thing about mobile add-ons
is that they're native Android apps
which means if you already have an
Android app you can make it into a
mobile add-on and you can also invoke
server-side functions in Apps Script by
using the execution API this code is an
example of how you would do that but
it's relatively simple you just create a
request
and build this operation type and then
you can send it to to app script using
this API and it'll execute
asynchronously and you can get the
results when you're ready so a good
example of mobile add-on is EasyBib
built in mobile add-on they already had
a mobile app and what their add-on does
is it integrates with Docs so you can go
into the add-ons menu in Docs you can
select the EasyBib app and that will
take you into you into their app where
you can search for the citation that
you're looking for for your paper and
you can add it and you can you can add
it to your bibliography and say the
cited and the doc that'll cause that
entry to get inserted into your doc and
you'll be back in the doc like you never
left
and so this creates a much tighter
integration where you don't have to jump
between mobile apps it's all handled by
the out on developer so new features you
might have heard announcement this
morning from pravakar Gmail add-ons are
on the way we're really excited about
this launch we think that people are
gonna be able to do really cool things
with Gmail and if you want to find out
more if you want to be one of those
people that's doing really cool things
with Gmail we have a session at next
they encourage you to attend it's right
here in the Marriott in salon 6 at 5:20
today title of the talk is a new way to
integrate your app into Gmail another
another launch that we've got coming up
slides out ons it's also going to be a
really cool new feature and you have the
opportunity to sign up for the Early
Access program now you can go to this
link
to sign up for the early access program
I'll give you a second to copy it down
or you can ask me after a talk and I'll
give it to you and then for more
information also feel free to visit
developers.google.com slash slides where
i've been promised there will be more
info on slides add-ons everybody who
wanted to get an opportunity to copy
this done all right awesome so what next
where do we go from here well first of
all I invite you to go to
developers.google.com slash apps -
script this is a great resource our
developer relations team some of whom
are actually in the audience have done a
really awesome job of putting together
QuickStart guides tutorials reference
documents and information about our
early access program the QuickStart
guides in particular of interest if
you're interested in add-ons because we
have a Quick Start Guide for docs
add-ons and for forms add-ons they only
take about five minutes to go through
they're incredibly informative I've done
them myself and very useful and you'll
learn a lot also I'd encourage you to
watch more YouTube just in general but
if you want to learn about Apps Script
we've got some really great tutorials we
have online on the Apps Script platform
unfortunately we don't have a talk yet
on add-ons
although Wesley I hope you'll add one
[Laughter]
but these are a really great resource if
you're just getting started with Apps
Script you can learn a lot from these
videos and then since you're right next
I encourage you to take advantage the
opportunity to attend more next sessions
on this topic in particular we're gonna
have a talk on how to use stock driver
logging and bigquery to do monitoring
the analytics this is going to be really
interesting and it's a rare opportunity
to get inside
into how to leverage these technologies
and I think it could be very useful to
out on developers is successful add-on
can easily have tens of thousands of
users that's gonna take place in Moscone
West in room 2010 at four o'clock which
is the next breakout session but you
have to choose because there is also a
talk on Doc's api's and Apps Script
taking place here in the Marriott in
salon seven also at 4:00 p.m. and it's
also incredibly useful for people
interested in add-ons because this talk
is going to help you learn how to
integrate with the Docs editors and
finally as I mentioned there's going to
be a session on Gmail add-ons here in
the Marriott at 5:20 in salon 6 so with
that I'd like to invite you all to
publish your own add-on think about what
you need build it decide do you want to
share it with you can publish it to the
world or you can publish it to your
business but build something cool and
when you when you've published it it'll
know that it'll be easy for users to
install whether they want to install it
one user at a time or whether businesses
want to install it to their domain and
remember that we have this tight launch
and iterate cycle that's made possible
by being a cloud platform and take
advantage of that so that you can
publish early and often and remember
that because you're building on Apps
Script it's going to be easy to
integrate with Google services like
Gmail and calendar and drive you can do
lots of cool things this way and we'll
take care of a lot of the details like
like the auth to security model and make
it easy for you to make a rich
experience in the Google ecosystem
you